well let's just bring you some breaking
news that's just coming into us now and
that is that um sarah harding who is the
singer and actress has passed away
there she is there you can see her her
mother
said a message on instagram
to say that it's with deep heartbreak
that today i'm sharing the news that my
beautiful daughter sarah has sadly
passed away
many of you will know of sarah's battle
with cancer and that she fought so
strongly from her diagnosis until her
last day
she slipped away peacefully this morning
i'd like to thank everyone for their
kind support over the past year it meant
the world to sarah and it gave her great
strength and comfort to know that she
was loved
i know she won't um
want to be remembered for her fight
against this terrible disease
she was a fight a bright
shining star and i hope
that she can be remembered
instead i hope that's how she can be
remembered instead that's sarah's mother
marie sarah hardin who's age 39 she was
a member of girls allows she rose to
fame in 2002 following that reality tv
program pop star the rivals and of
course she won and got into the girl
bound girls allowed because of her
amazing singing voice so that is the
news that's just coming into us now
sarah harding aged 39
who's just passed away
her mother has just confirmed